jorge garcía órgano del comité por la
libertad de milagro sala en canadá
quienes milagro salá y cuáles son las
razones por las cuales ella está
detenida en la argentina
primero muchas gracias por darnos la
oportunidad de expresar de contarles lo
que está pasando con milagro salas y
y otra gente detenida en la argentina-
milagro salá es la dirigente la
secretaria general de la organización
barrial tupac amaru que se inició en el
año 2004 en la provincia de jujuy en el
norte oeste argentino
en realidad la actividad empieza en el
año 2000 con el gran desempleo la crisis
económica con un grupo principalmente de
mujeres creando lugares donde los niños
podían ir a recibir un pan un vaso de
leche para no ir con hambre a la escuela
que ahí empieza a creer a crecer y crear
comedores populares donde familias
enteras te van a alimentar recibiendo
contribuciones de sindicatos de algunos
empresarios de algunos negocios en el
año 2004
esta organización principalmente de
mujeres llega a la conclusión de que la
pobreza no se sale con caridad se sale
con trabajo decente vivienda digna salud
para todos
en la organización barrial tupac amaru
la organización barrial tupac amaru
recurre y aplica como muchas otras
organizaciones al gobierno para recibir
dinero para construcción de viviendas
como pasa en todas partes del mundo
la diferencia es que la organización
barrial tupac amaru cuando recibió
dinero del gobierno para construir
viviendas en lugar de contratar a una
compañía constructora que viene trae sus
arquitectos sus trabajadores y como es
una compañía privada se queda con un
beneficio empezó a construir viviendas
ellas mismas principalmente mujeres que
aprendieron plomería carpintería que
aprendieron a hacer sus ventanas y
empezaron a construir sus propias casas
recibiendo un salario en el proceso
aprendieron que los ladrillos se pueden
construir también se construyó una
cooperativa para hacer ladrillos se
construyó una cooperativa para construir
las ventanas de metal necesitaban
uniformes se construyó una cooperativa
de mujeres para construir los uniformes
de los trabajadores
en ese proceso descubren que
construyendo las casas ellos mismos
pagando sus salarios comprando los
materiales que ellos fabrican sobra
dinero las ganancias de la empresa no se
las lleva a nadie quedan las manos de
las cooperativas y con ese dinero
empiezan a agregar en los barrios salas
de salud escuelas y zonas de recreación
inclusive con piscinas piletas de
natación y esto se convierte en un
círculo virtuoso porque con las escuelas
y las fábricas textiles empiezan a
construir uniformes para los niños
siguen creciendo en un momento dado las
cooperativas ligadas a la tupac amaru
porque no es la única organización sino
que luego se fueron uniendo con otras
cooperativas se convirtieron en el
tercer empleador de la provincia de
jujuy
jujuy es una provincia muy pobre
pero el gobierno ha sido históricamente
el que más trabajo ha dado y los
ingenios azucareros principalmente el
ingenio ledesma en un momento dado la
organización barrial tupac amaru
dirigida por milagro salá y las otras
cooperativas ligadas a la organización
tenían tantos trabajadores como los que
estaban trabajando en ingenio ledesma y
casi tantos como los que trabajaban para
el gobierno jujeño ahora en este proceso
la organización y sus cooperativas
empezaron a funcionar también de forma
diferente empezaron a darse cuenta que
el dinero que ellos recibían que tenía
parecía que valía más que los otros
dinero de las compañías privadas porque
le daban más cosas a la gente la gente
terminaba con más beneficios de ese
dinero y empezaron a buscar formas de
organizarse y cómo seguir gastando ese
dinero en cada cooperativa eligieron
delegados y en cada barrio eligieron un
delegado y estos delegados
se convirtieron en lo que se puede
llamar el parlamento
de la organización tupac amaru y de las
otras cooperativas y en ese parlamento
se empezaron a tomar sus propias
decisiones entonces
esta forma de vivir en donde lo
colectivo es más importante que lo
individual en donde la riqueza no queda
en los bolsillos de algunos sino se
reparte empezó a ser un ejemplo y la
tupac amaru empezó a crecer en otros
lugares de argentina principalmente en
las provincias cercanas salta santiago
del estero porque ofrecía no sólo una
promesa sino una forma concreta de vida
diferente
esto esto causó muchos problemas para
los sectores más conservadores de la
provincia
de la argentina en general de la
provincia de jujuy en particular que es
muy conservadora porque cuestionaba el
poder principalmente de los hombres
blancos hay que recordar perdón o olvidé
decir milagro sala es una indígena cola
y la mayoría de los participantes de los
miembros de sus cooperativas son gente
aborigen son gente de pueblos
originarios entonces estos hombres
blancos acostumbrados a dominar se
encuentran que una mujer india y un
montón de indios le están cuestionando
en la práctica en la realidad que hacen
qué derechos tienen y les cuestionan
esencialmente el derecho de quedarse con
los beneficios
en enero de 2016 pocos días después de
la asunción del presidente mauricio
macri de una tendencia económica
neoliberal de una posición política
conservadora el gobernador de la
provincia de jujuy gerardo morales de la
misma fuerza política que el presidente
macri ordenó la detención de milagro
salas y de otra serie de dirigentes de
la organización tupac amaru y de otras
cooperativas
en su momento a un periodista gerardo
morales el gobernador le dijo tengo 60
causas contra milagrosa la que nadie
entendió muy bien eso lo que significó
fue que milagro salá y sus compañeras y
compañeros detenidos eran liberados de
una causa de alguna acusación pero
inmediatamente le ponían otra y entonces
desde que fue detenida nunca en estos
cinco años ya estuvo libertad milagro
salá a pesar de que se le dieron
libertad en una serie de causas donde
milagros a las es una dirigente indígena
popular de una serie de cooperativas que
además y creo que esto es importante fue
diputada en el congreso provincial de
jujuy y luego fue elegida al congreso
del mercosur lo que se llama el parlasur
y fue detenida siendo diputada del
parlasur
viendo todas las obligaciones de
inmunidad que tienen los diputados a
pesar de eso la detuvieron y el gobierno
de mauricio macri gobierno federal que
es responsable de la representación de
los argentinos en el mercosur tampoco
dijo nada y dejó que se violara la
inmunidad parlamentaria
y otros locales porque un comité por la
libertad de milagro sala en canadá
muchas gracias de doctor me gustaría ser
doctor pero no soy en canadá
nosotros que llegamos de otros países
los canadienses apreciamos la democracia
sentimos que se puede vivir respetando a
los otros a veces nos da miedo lo que
acaba de pasar en eeuu que pueda pasar
acá pero sentimos que es distante
sentimos que aquí se respeta la ley
entonces cuando uno ve cosas como las
que pasa con milagros a las en la
argentina- indigna y uno que ha pasado
por situaciones personalmente la mía de
haber sido detenido durante una
dictadura militar sabemos lo importante
que es defender la democracia aquí o en
otros lados entonces cuando nos
enteramos de las irregularidades legales
basadas principalmente
en un cuestionamiento a la forma de
manejar la economía y en un odio o un
racismo contra la clase contra los
pueblos indígenas pensamos que era
importante levantar la voz hacer conocer
la situación de lo que está pasando en
este caso en la argentina y buscar
también la oportunidad de que el
gobierno canadiense
haga conocer al gobierno argentino que
no está de acuerdo que no piensa que sea
correcto esa forma de tratar a sus
ciudadanos precisamente eso quería
preguntarle qué rol puede jugar canadá
para favorecer la liberación de milagro
sala
y los ciudadanos canadienses siempre
pueden como se ha hecho históricamente y
en muchos otros casos mandar cartas a la
corte suprema de justicia pidiendo la
libertad como ha pasado en muchos casos
en muchos países del mundo
la presión individual de cada uno es
importante la presión gubernamental es
la presión diplomática de ninguna manera
pensamos que canadá va a ir e invadir
argentina pero diplomáticamente canadá
puede poner presiones para que se
respete la ley para que se respete el
debido proceso para que la gente que
está detenida
con irregularidades judiciales se les
respete las derechos constitucionales y
los derechos que le otorgan los tratados
internacionales
nuestra intención nuestro objetivo es
conseguir el apoyo del gobierno
canadiense en esta necesidad de
recuperar la democracia completa con la
argentina queremos decir que en el año
2016 estuvimos contentos ilusionados
porque en la visita que hizo a la
argentina el primer ministro justin
theroux 2 conociendo la situación de
milagro salá privadamente y públicamente
le pidió al presidente argentino
mauricio macri que
tuviera atención pusiera atención a la
forma en que estaba siendo tratada
legalmente
milagrosa la pidiendo que se respetará
la ley eso nos llenó de ilusión pensamos
que a la vuelta
el primer ministro canadiense justin
crudo iba a poder seguir con esa
actividad poniendo presión buscando que
se respete la ley pero
nos encontramos con una sorpresa
el primer ministro justin crudo nuestro
primer ministro se llamó a silencio
desde ese momento le hemos enviado
cartas que le ha pasado a los ministros
de relaciones internacionales que no nos
han contestado tampoco nos han dicho que
iba a haber reuniones de reuniones de
eso para discusión de derechos humanos
entre argentina y canadá hemos tratado
de ponernos en contacto con global
affairs y parecería que o no son
públicas o no se han hecho ninguna
reunión
y lo que fue un momento de esperanza de
que el gobierno canadiense iba a actuar
en defensa de la democracia en la
argentina quedó en silencio nos llamamos
a pensar
preguntándonos qué puede haber pasado
aquí por qué
un primer ministro
que se entera de una situación que pide
públicamente que se repare esa situación
luego sin ninguna razón para el pablo se
llama al silencio y lamentablemente la
conclusión que yo llego y solamente yo
me hago responsable de esto es que los
capitales dineros canadienses han puesto
presión sobre el primer ministro en la
argentina al año 78 la o información
oficial que hemos podido encontrar del
gobierno de canadá en la argentina en el
año 78 en el ateneo 2018 había 49
compañías mineras canadienses con una
inversión de 11.000 millones de dólares
y lo más importante
a febrero del 2020 que la última fecha
que pudimos conseguir hay 12 compañías
mineras canadienses en jujuy
y tratando de entrar en la minería del
litio y esto es algo importante que no
le he comentado al audi a la audiencia
el norte de la provincia de jujuy junto
con bolivia y chile conforman lo que se
llama el triángulo del litio 80% del
litio mundial está en esa zona nosotros
sabemos la importancia del litio estamos
contentos con nuestras baterías en las
computadoras en los teléfonos ahora
queremos baterías en los coches para
ahorrar
petróleo y no contaminar el 80 por
ciento del litio que se necesita para
esas baterías está en esa zona de
américa latina- y jugó hoy está metido
12 compañías mineras canadiense están
tratando de hacer negocio en el norte de
jujuy donde milagro salá está presa
alguna empieza a juntar estas pequeñas
piezas y empieza a armarse un
rompecabezas en donde uno empieza a
decir bueno a lo mejor el ministro el
primer ministro ya está incluido en la
argentina no sabía de la minería
canadiense en jujuy del litio entonces
dijo lo que sentía que era justo cuando
se enteró que había otros intereses se
llamó a silencio yo no tengo ningún
inconveniente creo que ninguno de
nosotros tiene inconveniente de que un
gobierno defienda los intereses de su
país y trate de conseguir el crecimiento
económico de su país
en otros lugares es el trabajo se puede
decir inclusive de un gobierno pero
cuando un gobierno pone los intereses
económicos por encima de los derechos
humanos por encima de la defensa de la
democracia uno empieza a tener dudas
acerca de la idoneidad de esos tipos de
gobierno que la vuelta benefician
a los intereses económicos por encima de
los derechos humanos por último usted
nos dio un buen contexto de marco
económico y político en el que se generó
el conflicto que llevó a la prisión a
milagro sala
ahora bien el gobierno de la provincia
de jujuy el norte de la argentina sigue
siendo el mismo signo político de cuando
esos acontecimientos ocurrieron pero el
gobierno nacional argentino ha cambiado
ha vuelto a manos de quienes tenían la
administración del país en momentos en
que es el movimiento tupac amaru surgió
que hace entonces que milagro salá siga
detenida en la argentina si las razones
para que se haya desoído fallos
judiciales en su momento fueron
políticas no se podría ejercer también
ahora esa influencia política en
beneficio de la libertad hay también
intereses actuales dentro de la
administración nacional argentina que
impidan que la causa avance hacia una
resolución definitiva
empecemos diciendo que el actual
presidente de la argentina alberto
fernández fue uno de los primeros
políticos argentinos en apoyar a milagro
salas cuando fue detenida y a todo lo
largo
alberto fernández ha estado apoyando a
milagro salas como presidente y antes de
ser presidente milagro perdón a alberto
fernández dice dijo y dirá públicamente
de que milagro sala está injustamente
detenida pero alberto fernández y
respeta la democracia y alberto
fernández yo estoy seguro estoy seguro
que estará tratando de hacer lo que
puede para influenciar a la corte
suprema pero alberto fernández como
presidente no puede darle la libertad a
milagro salas porque es una decisión del
poder judicial y no es una posición del
presidente del país alguna gente me ha
preguntado por qué alberto fernández no
hace como trump que perdonó a todos sus
amigos
alberto fernández ha declarado desde
mucho tiempo antes inclusive de ser
candidato a presidente que los perdones
presidenciales eran una rémora de la
monarquía que el presidente no tiene por
qué darle perdón a nadie porque él
quiere que para eso existen mecanismos
debidamente reglamentados en la
democracia como son los poderes el poder
judicial en primer lugar y las amnistía
de los congresos que son los las voces
elegidas por la gente para llevar
adelante eso el presidente en la opinión
de alberto gonzález no puede perdonar
porque es actuar injustamente violando
las reglas de la democracia
en este sentido creo
que a mí no me gusta lo que está pasando
pero tengo que respetar al presidente
alberto fernández que pone respeto a la
democracia y a las leyes
constitucionales por encima de la
defensa de la gente que él apoya y
respeta muy brevemente cuáles son los
próximos pasos que va a dar aquí en
canadá el comité
estamos discutiendo justamente los
próximos pasos hemos empezado a trabajar
con organizaciones de pueblos
originarios canadienses para crear una
conexión con los pueblos originarios de
jujuy hemos estado hablando con una
serie de abogados sobre qué
posibilidades hay de influenciar a la
corte suprema argentina desde aquí hemos
estado hablando con gente de la tupac
amaru que queda en la argentina para ver
la posibilidad de algún proyecto de
apoyo a las escuelas y a los comedores
para niños en la zona de jujuy que de
vuelta es una zona muy pobre en este
momento estamos con dos o tres proyectos
estudiando a ver dónde podemos poner
nuestro esfuerzo muy bien jorge garcía
organiza el comité por la libertad de
milagro salá en canadá muchas gracias
por tu entrevista con radio canadá
internacional muchas gracias por la
atención que nos han prestado